campaña erdogan dijo que los turcos no
iban a sacrificar a su líder por
cebollas y patatas cómo es la situación
para el ciudadano medio en el día a día
y que representa para ellos
no la situación económica en Turquía es
muy difícil y inclusive los grupos que
han apoyado a erdogan en el pasado están
muy decepcionados con su desempeño y
porque no ha propuesto nuevas medidas
para mejorar la situación económica
vemos un pueblo Turco una clase media
turca empobrecida y Jóvenes turcos que
están viendo las posibilidades de dejar
el país y esto es algo que impactó
muchísimo en su fracaso electoral aunque
no fue tal fracaso electoral como muchos
pensábamos Porque casi gana el 50% de la
votación
pensamos que la situación del del
terremoto en febrero donde murieron
50.000 personas y también toda la
debacle alrededor de los permisos que se
dieron para la construcción de de estas
de estos edificios que fueron muy
irregulares y que asociado con ciertos
grupos cercanos a erdogan pensamos que
todo esto como especialistas iba a tener
un impacto mayor pero no ha sido tanto
así el pueblo Turco todavía ve en la
figura de erdogan un líder fuerte que le
dio un progreso económico a Turquía en
los dos mil y principios de 2010 y le ha
perdonado le ha perdonado hasta cierto
punto alguno de sus de sus errores pero
no obstante vemos que que la oposición
ha acogido un auge tremendo y son una
serie amenazas para para
y más allá de esto de que nos Comenta
este auge económico del principio de los
2000 que ha hecho mal erdogan para que
la lira ahora este niveles mínimos
bueno él ha cometido muchos errores pero
no olvidemos que erdogan ha querido
proyectar a Turquía como un líder
regional y ha empezado a hacer muchas
intervenciones militares no solamente en
medio oriente sino también en África no
hay un problema de inflación que no ha
podido manejar y no de no ha seguido Los
consejos de los economistas del país
para controlar el alza en los precios
también hay que ver que que esta
inversión que han hecho que le ha hecho
envolverse en la guerra en Siria la
cantidad de soldados turcos que tienen
presencia militar en otros países
también es algo que afecta
económicamente las arcas del país